all right tonight for the hour we're
going to highlight a serious divisive
problem that persists all over this
country mainly among democrats their
friends and big tech the media mob
time and time again these powerful
individuals and they are powerful
they create rules they themselves don't
follow now some call it hypocrisy others
refer to it as a double standard in
reality it's fraud deception for the
purpose of political gain and power it's
about forcing your kids to wear a mask
during recess even while adults pack
into a crowded arena not a mask in sight
it's about twitter facebook they censor
the very true hunter biden laptop report
while allowing the fake salacious claims
in the dirty dossier the russian dirty
dossier that hillary paid for oh that
could circulate all day every day every
every place everywhere it's about joe
rogan becoming enemy number one for
having an open dialogue and daring to
ask questions that i guess are
inappropriate
rachel maddow she faces
zero repercussions for deliberately
lying to her viewers about oh trump
russia collusion for how many years
it's about fake news cnn obsessively
condemning january 6. the riot that took
place uh but then never talking about
the 574 riots in the summer of 2020 that
left dozens of people dead they
characterized those riots as mostly
peaceful even when the city's burning
behind their reporter right over their
shoulder it's about whoopi goldberg
whoopi recently made comments about the
holocaust minimize the horrors of what
was racist genocide here's what she said
take a look
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race it's not about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
the minute you turn it into race it goes
down this alley
now she was right on the evil portion of
her comments but of course she was wrong
on everything else now she has since
acknowledged it rightfully apologized
clarified her remarks but think about
this if whoopi goldberg were a
conservative or republican uh wouldn't
she be fired already or at the very
least
being bombarded with boycotts and
serious repercussions you know on this
program and over the entire course of my
career i've steadfastly refused to join
calls to boycott and fire and have
people canceled now look i've known
whoopi for years we haven't talked
recently i'll say that i haven't gone
back on the show in a long time but and
we never agree politically
i simply see her being inarticulate and
maybe not even understanding the evil
ideology that was hitler and nazi
germany um
she's she's not anti-semitic from the
person that i knew i read people pretty
well it's obvious her comments were
grossly inaccurate she's rightly
apologized she's clarified her remarks
um i don't know maybe i'm old-fashioned
i just believe in second chances and i'm
pretty confident she's never going to
make that same mistake again yeah and i
know nobody at the view would ever do
this for a conservative ever hell would
freeze over but here's the great thing
about living in a free country if you
don't like what whoopi goldberg said
guess what change the channel if you
don't like her show change the channel
you don't like stephen colbert kim
o'fallon constantly shilling for
democrats telling bad jokes don't watch
it no one is forcing you to you don't
have to tune in censorship via big
government corporations is never the
answer tonight i'm calling on everyone
on all these other networks you're on
abc nbc cbs msdnc fake news cnn you need
to denounce censorship and stop with the
boycotts and stop with the feigned moral
outrage and you know what none of you
are perfect either and when you make a
mistake you should get the same
forgiveness if you're sincere in your
apology that's never going to happen
dishonesty hacks you know the the humpty
dumpty's of the world they love
censorship they want fox off the air
they want conservatives on talk radio
silence they want republicans out of
power forever and they detest even the
sight of donald trump they detest
competition especially because they're
losing so badly so they don't care about
truth fairness freedom forgiveness none
of that that's why just a few hours
after joe rogan apologized which i don't
think he should have done
for potentially spreading misinformation
the media continued to attack him in joe
rogan's case i'm arguing he didn't need
to apologize at all the left wants to
squash all dissent they won't they won't
stop until everyone that disagrees with
them is silenced hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else